und dann feiern wir diese woche
natürlich noch zehn jahre große
bankenkrise
zehn jahre ist das schon wieder her dass
wir da alle opfer eines großen gängen
bankings wurden ja ja damals nach der
lehman pleite
das einzige was die banker aus dem
debakel gelernt haben ist dass wir sie
im ernstfall sowieso retten
vor allem europa zahlt heute noch für
die krise fielen gar nicht klar wir
zahlen immer noch die sparer werden zum
beispiel durch niedrigzinsen enteignet
weil sonst diverse länder in südeuropa
bankrottgehen länder die damals banken
retten mussten allein die deutsche bank
hat immer noch massenhaft alte derivate
im keller ja auch die waren damals fett
mit dabei die deutsche bank ging 2005
dazu über die kredit bündel bewusst mit
geplatzten hypotheken vollzustopfen man
verkaufe einen haufen scheiße sagte ein
banker am telefon
ich empfehle ihnen als geldanlage einen
haufen scheiße und glauben sie mir ich
habe für sowas ein riecher jene
vierköpfige deutsche familie hat schon
jetzt rund 3000 euro für arme banken
gespendet von ihnen übrigens hier jetzt
nicht im heute-show fanshop das ehrliche
sparbuch kommen hier ganz toll wenn man
das auch klappt dann lacht ein ein
banker ausgemacht da war wunderbar
schön oder
und ich sag mal im grunde kann man den
banker an sich gar keinen vorwurf machen
wenn man kann ja auch nicht von dem
pitbull verlangen dass er plötzlich
veganer wird ist gegen die natur in rain
sie können hat hier genauso wenig
kontrollieren wie die geilheit von
teenagern was für [ __ ] also teenager
ein teenager
leider habe ich mir die ganzen dokus
über zehn jahre lang im fernsehen
wirklich rein gezogen und ich kann nur
sagen davon kriegt man depressionen was
damals passiert ist vor zehn jahren kann
sich jederzeit wiederholen nur dass es
beim nächsten mal garantiert viel
schlimmer wird ja dem deutschen
bankenverband ist das problem aber
durchaus bewusst deswegen haben sie
jetzt carolin kebekus engagiert ja die
als eine art stimmungskanone durch
deutsche fußgängerzonen tingelt um vor
bankfilialen dem deutschen sparer die
angst zu nehmen
wie genau macht man das zelt ganz
einfach alle war offensives marketing
wir sagen nicht oh gott es kommt die
nächste bankenkrise wir sagen knack ob
die nächste bankenkrise und die wird
noch fitter noch teurer noch geiler
diesmal bleibt nichts übrig davon wissen
wir uns doch die stimmung nicht
vermiesen
wir sind bald pleite
leute wie boris becker wir sind erledigt
und 74
richtig
vielen dank an der ecke
recke den meisten deutschen ist das
thema viel zu komplex und es kommt noch
gar keine flüchtlinge drin vor
dabei müssten der sparer mit fackeln und
mistgabeln auf die straße gehen ich sag
nur derivate finanzwetten die haben im
vergleich zu 2008 drastisch zugenommen
um ein drittel
das einzige was seitdem mehr zugenommen
hat ist oliver welke das ist lustig
verpackt ist
[Applaus]
es ist praktisch eine situation die
ziemlich an das erinnert was vor der
krise da war nur dass die fallhöhe wenn
ich mal so sagen darf gestiegen ist das
sind jetzt weiter oben und wir fallen
franken tiefer sein ex-arbeitgeber die
deutsche bank arbeitet immer noch mit
gerade mal etwas mehr als vier prozent
eigenkapital
das ist wahnsinn warum zog ihr und
alkohol
entschuldigung entscheidung erstens ich
schäme mich wieder mal für jeden der mit
klatsch zweitens die zocken ja weniger
auch bei der deutschen bank und mit
solchen blöden mallorca helfen oder gar
keinem weiter gute haben sie absolut
recht ja ja die deutsche bank hat
[Musik]
vielen dank ihr seid super gute laune
trotz apokalypse klar
heute gibt's hochfrequenzhandel also
zockende computer es gibt immer mehr
schattenbanken die gar keiner
kontrolliert und viele staaten sind
selber so verschuldet dass sie kein geld
mehr haben wo banken zu retten alles
richtig aber sehen wir auch mal das
positive wenn der nächste crash kommt
wird dieser mann uns alle retten sollte
ich jedes amtes enthoben werden würden
die märkte zusammenbrechen alle wären
dann sehr arm
denn ohne dieses hören hier sehen die
wirtschaftsdaten ganz anders aus absolut
ohne dieses gehirn sehr gerne verloren
und um es mal so auszudrücken aber
scheiß drauf krise ist voll einmal im
jahr
olé
einmal
unschön
aber scheu
juni keine putts und sängerknaben und
[Applaus]
[Musik]